thank you for talking to me i was um
fascinated by this movie in these this
oh my gosh i'm really excited to
get um a steer for how it's going to go
down in the states it's quite um
yeah i'm interested what do you think
i i'm very interested to hear what men
would say about it as opposed to women i
think that also
is a very interesting
conversation yes yes i'm sure
um
okay well well fire ahead i'll see what
i can see
well what was it that sparked the idea
for doing this was there something you
were looking to explore something you
wanted to say i mean how did it start
um well i guess it started um
[Music]
because uh
during my late 20s and early 30s when i
had my second son
i started fit to feel this sort of
enormous pressure
um and this sort of
cultural steer towards um
uh this habit all culture um that would
seem to be angled that women uh
particularly and
you know you can
[Music]
the sort of messaging that was like you
can have kids and go to work and be
massively successful you can do
everything you can do everything really
well and
you know it won't cost you anything
except your sanity which is what i saw
um and i experienced myself on some
level and and continue to um so i
what was so funny was that the sort of
world was suggesting that
um we can we can do all of these things
and yes we can but there are there is um
as i said before there is a there is a
cost and all i could see around me
at this most sort of like
um
what i would say was a liberated time
was like a common female crisis and i
wanted to talk a bit more honestly about
that with other women i guess ultimately
and it's not i guess i mean it's not
just about modern feminism it's also
about
how we can kind of coexist as men and
women now
um what that actually looks like
um what this sort of female modern
movement has
has done to men
how people behave when they're rejected
um financial disparity like all of it
it's all it's all in there on some level
you've collaborated as a producer on
secret diary of call girl and i hate
susie but what made this the project
that you wanted to tackle as a writer
and a director
well i guess like
it's i
i love movies um
i felt like i wasn't ever reading um a
script that was
entirely honest about what it meant to
be a woman um
i think things have improved since i
started writing the script i started
writing it like
i keep saying seven years ago but it's
actually nine years ago so my son's now
nine
um so
the the landscape has changed you know
considerably but obviously there's still
a way to go that said
um i i didn't i didn't recognize myself
or my peers in the things that i was
watching
and so it felt like something that um
[Music]
i just i don't know i just felt very
headstrong about um taking full control
of the entire thing i i what i was gonna
i was gonna write i i was writing it
directing it and was gonna like exec i
mean write it star in it and exec
and it wasn't until the sort of end
kind of close to it getting financed
that um
i said i'm going to direct it to
is it more challenging to stare down the
blank page and write a script or is it
more challenging to direct yourself
acting
um
it's
more challenging to sit down and
start writing i think um
it's really it's tiring and
really confusing directing yourself but
it's it's
my my sort of vanity
um that i have as an actor
uh was very quickly
uh
very quickly subsided and i
was able to watch myself on screen and
not feel
um
in any way judgmental of the way i
looked or
or anything like that which i i thought
was going to be a challenge but because
when i do sort of self tapes you know
often you're like well this is
[ __ ] basically
[ __ ] i'm going to do it a hundred times
i hate the way i look hate son of my
voice
all the stuff that you know most actors
can attest to i think but um
uh
and i got over that instinct really
really quickly so definitely sitting
down and writing is is is more of a
challenge
was this a script that you wrote and
finished and then went and shot what was
on the page or was there an evolution to
what you wrote did you make a lot of
changes over a period of time
um
i would say that the the the film that
you see is pretty loyal to the original
script there's a few scenes that were
cut because it was just
repressive
um and then the cerium wasn't doing any
more pedaling and
um
but it didn't change dramatically from
um
uh
i don't know i don't know what number
draft it was on by the time we ended up
filming it it wasn't
it wasn't a frightening amount of
giraffes i'm i'm
i guess maybe a bit
too lazy for that or i don't know but i
i it was what you see is is very close
to
where i ended up with the writing
process
i think along the way either in the
script form or once you had shot it and
had a finished movie did you
show it to anybody for did anybody give
you any kind of good feedback or advice
that really that you feel really sort of
helped guide you
yes i went to a few people i went to my
closest collaborator um
and
best friend lucy preble who
um
i worked with on well i've worked with
all
for the last 15 years and
most recently we did i hope susie
together
um and she came into the edit suite at
um
the time when i felt very confused by
the edit and i wasn't
entirely sure all of it was making sense
and sure enough i mean she is like the
queen of clarity so she found
she was like none of it makes sense
um no she she wasn't but she was you
know she was tough in places where it
needed um
some some guidance um
and then we showed it to a handful of
people
um some of the editors friends and
producers and stuff and um it's really
yeah it was it was quite a challenging
time because look this film isn't going
to be for everyone it is very very
divisive um but both in its its tone
it's style
it's storytelling um
it's not
i
terribly mainstream it's quite a lot the
characters are very unforgiving and very
coarse and so
i you know i got a lot of criticisms up
up front um
and and what i realized is it just
genuinely comes down to
people's taste in which cloth they're
cut from and what their experiences of
life have been
um because there was there was no way to
sort of bend that film and make it more
palatable
and every time i did do that in a sort
of knee-jerk reaction to what someone
had said
it started to feel really diluted and
really
even more confused
it's interesting for some reason it's
always jarring when a woman gets slapped
what was it like to do
that scene where mandy slaps peed and
then pete slaps me at me back and what
made you want to include that
um because
i've often
um
had
when you talk about sort of equal rights
or um equality and
male female sort of straight
relationships and
quite often you know that is weighted
back at you about you know what if in in
only with really stupid people who um
kind of mis
what can i say that's
more diplomatic um
i can't um
so
yeah just stupid people who um sort of
made that error
of
suggesting well you know she she hit me
i should be able to whack her back um
um
this is when it comes to sort of arguing
about
um
equality in in the male female dynamic i
guess um
but i mean it's it's a really sort of
warped and confused and
exhausting conversation that doesn't
really go anywhere
i've seen some sort of terrible behavior
in my life from people um in the face of
in the face of rejection and and
um people who are really really scared
can do some really really mean things um
and
so i just wanted to include it in
all of its brutality i guess
was that something you had a lot of
conversations about when you shot that
scene i mean did you speak to the actor
about it or did you just
say you know this is what it is so we're
gonna have to just go for it
i did say i just said this is what it is
this is what it means
i think i'm just gonna have to go for it
i mean it's
we affected the sound of it
um in post-production
um but
um
but it but i felt it let's say
but i think i was running on such huge
amounts of um
adrenaline at that period because it's
right at the end of the shoot it was
literally the last um four no last three
days
um
that i'm not sure i would have felt
anything physically because i was so
disassociated from my body in at that
stage in the process of making the movie
which is slightly alarming considering i
was pregnant
um but i
it was a it was i was in a i was in an i
was operating in another space entirely
you previously talked about how you want
to work with your friends and that you
only want to do work that is meaningful
to you and that you can be invested in
what are you doing to make sure that
continues to happen does that mean
you're you are going to be more involved
creatively with every project you do now
how are you figuring that out
yeah i feel like i just want to
not work
all the time um work on things that i
feel aligned with and really excite me
and mean i can push forwards
even more
if that feels necessary
um
but i think when you're creating
something from the ground up
it's quite hard especially with the
family to do that
a handful of times in a year so for me
my biggest challenge at the moment is
trying to work out um
how to just
uh
kick back a bit
and i really found going from being
pregnant
filming
rare beasts directing it post-production
with a
brand new baby girl into i hate susie i
think it just knocked my butt like block
off and i so
my quest moving forward is is is
definitely
working um
with people on things
that have either come from me or things
that are very inspiring
all really fun things with fun people
that don't take up a lot of time
um or just not working
what do you feel you've learned from the
experience of directing that you think
might influence or change how you do it
the next time
i wouldn't be in it
um
i would work
closely with a producer that
um i've just recently worked with
um and who is
very very good on script i think that's
really really important um
i would
uh
but otherwise
um
i don't know
what i would
change i just i guess it's part of an
evolution so things will naturally be
different and hopefully better and more
refined but i can't guarantee that
but definitely not be in it is the the
the one the first thing that kind of
comes to mind
well i appreciate you
talking about clearly you had a very
clear vision and feeling for this film
so i'm very excited to see what else you
do in that way next so
thank you thanks so much